[موسيقى]
ونبقى معكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المستمره للذكرى الاولى لبدء حرب روسيا في
اوكرانيا
ارسلت بولندا اليوم الدفعه الاولى من
دبابات لوبارتو من اصل اربع عشره دبابه
كانت قد وعدت بها اوكرانيا واعلن رئيس
الوزراء البولندي ماتي عن ارسال الشحنه
الاولى خلال زيارته الى كييف تزامنا مع
ذكرى بدء العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا كانت بريطانيا والنرويج
وسلوفاكيا والولايات المتحده وفرنسا اعلنت
عن تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات في حربها ضد
روسيا
على الجانب الاخر وفي بريطانيا اعلن وزير
الدفاع البريطاني بن ولس ان بلاده لن تقوم
بتزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات تايفون في
المستقبل القريب واضاف ولسان امداد طائرات
المقاتله سيتطلب ارسال مئات الاشخاص بينهم
مهندسون وطيارون مشيرا الى ان الغرب لن
يرسل قوات الى اوكرانيا بهذا الحجم لكن
يمكن ان ترسل بريطانيا 200 شخص من سلاح
الجو الملكي في وقت اخر وليس في هذه
المرحله
من جهتها قالت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي سيواصل فرض العقوبات
على روسيا لتمكين اوكرانيا من الانتصار في
هذه الحرب
سوف نستمر في فرض العقوبات على روسيا سوف
نستمر في ملاحقه اتباع بوتين وهؤلاء الذين
يساعدون الروسيا لتجنب العقوبات او لتعزيز
ترسانتها العسكريه سوف نستمر في تقديم
الدعم المالي لاوكرانيا 67 مليار دولار
خصصناها حتى الان ثانيا مع زياده الدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا نهدف الى تدريب 30 الف
جندي اوكراني في الاتحاد الاوروبي سوف
نقوم بعمليه شراء مشتركه لايصال المعدات
العسكريه الطارئه الى اوكرانيا
وزير الماليه الالمانيه كريستيانو ان
بلاده لن يكون لديها عمل مع روسيا في
الوقت الراهن ولا في المستقبل القريب ايضا
طالما ان الحرب في اوكرانيا مستمره
لا يمكن ان يكون هناك عمل كالمعتاد مع
روسيا ولن يكون هناك عمل معها في المستقبل
طالما الحرب الروسيه الوحشيه مستمره على
اوكرانيا
ونحن نبقى معكم في تغطيه ذكرى هذه الحرب
من عواصم مختلفه وايضا من قلب الحدث من
دونيسكن راس العربيه رائد الاغبر ومن
برلين مراسله العربيه راغده بهنام يمكن ان
ابدا براغده هناك حاله من الترقب الشديد
لتداعيات هذا العام الاول على اوروبا وفي
الخطوط الاماميه منها بالطبع المانيا
المانيا فاعل رئيسي في اوروبا في هذه
الحرب كيف كانت التداعيات لديك راغده في
برلين الراي العام كيف تفاعل والدوائر
السياسيه ايضا
اهلا بك يتداعيات كبيره جدا في الواقع
المستشار الالماني اوبشول سماها بانها
نقطه التحول في خطابه الذي بات شهير
وتاريخي في الواقع هو خطاب القاه يعني بعد
ايام قليله من الحرب من بدء هذه الحرب
العام الماضي ومنذ ذلك الحين يتكرر هذا
التعبير دائما هنا في برلين بانه هذه
الحرب كانت نقطه تحول بالنسبه الينا كانت
نقطه تحول في نقطتين في الواقع من ناحيه
العقيده العسكريه لالمانيا دفعتها لتغيير
عقيدتها دفعتها لان تبدا بارسال اسلحه
لمناطق نزاع وهذا كان يعني امر لا تقوم به
المانيا منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
كانت تتخذ موقعا او موقفا مسالما اكثر لا
تتدخل بالنزاعات ولا ترسل اسلحه لهذه
المناطق ومن نقطه ثانيه ايضا اعتمادها على
الغاز الروسي باشهر قليله جدا رغم القلق
الكبير الذي كان محيط يعني هنا في المانيا
من تبعات وقف الغاز الروسي ولكن نجحت
بالفعل الحكومه الالمانيه بان تستبدل هذا
الغاز سريعا يعني بسبب رئيسي هي قدرتها
الشرائيه المرتفعه جدا اعلى من يعني اي
دوله اوروبيه اخرى
بالنسبه لدوائر الحكم في المانيا راغده
الشارع في المانيا كيف يتفاعل مع ذكرى هذه
الحرب الشارع تاثر بشكل كبير في اوروبا
بالتضخم بارتفاع اسعار الطاقه بالعديد من
الامور التي يمكن ان تكون قد اثرت بشكل
واضح على الحياه المعيشيه للمواطنين في
المانيا
هذه الحرب اثرت بشكل مباشر على المواطنين
بسبب ارتفاع فواتير الغاز والكهرباء وايضا
التضخم يعني ما يعني بانه كل شيء ارتفعت
اسعاره يعني تدخلين الى
المتاجر لشراء ماكولات وهذا يعني بانه
فاتورتك الان اغلب الكثير مما كانت في
الماضي عشرين ثلاثين بالمئه اغلى ولكن مع
ذلك استطلاعات الراي تشير بانه ما زال
هناك تاييد يعني معظم الالمان اكثر من 50%
من الالمان ما زالوا يؤيدون الاوكران في
هذه الحرب ما زالوا يؤيدون تاييد حكومتهم
ودعم حكومتهم يعني لاوكرانيا هناك تردد من
ناحيه ارسال الاسلحه ما اذا كان على
الحكومه الالمانيه ان تصدر ترسل هذه
الاسلحه الثقيله الى كييف ومن هنا ربما
يعني هذا التردد لدى الشعب السلماني ينعكس
تردد على الحكومه لان المتوسط دائما
زملائنا على الارض الذين يقومون بتقطيع
الميدانيه لهذه الحرب زميل احمد بهجت موفد
العربيه الى كراماتور ينضم الينا ايضا في
هذه التغطيه احمد اكراماتورسك من النقاط
الحيويه وكما يقال عنها الاستراتيجيه
بالنسبه لجبهات القتال في هذه المعركه كيف
تبدو الصوره لديك بعد عام من هذه الحرب
نعم رشا كما ذكرتي بالفعل يعني هناك
تخوف كبير من قبل
المواطنين هنا من ان الايام المقبله قد
تشهد مزيدا من الضربات الموجهه لهذه
المدينه مدينه كراماتوسك التي تقع في
منطقه او اقليم دونيتسك هذه المنطقه التي
تضررت بصوره كبيره نحن الان نقف امام احدى
الخنادق التي الموجوده في المدينه تحسبا
في اي وقت لدخول القوات الروسيه كما يقول
او كما تقول القياده العسكريه هنا لكن
الشيء الاهم هو ما يجري بالقرب من هذه
المدينه في مدينه بخموت عندما يتحدث عن
مخموت قوات تقوم بمهاجمه القوات
الاوكرانيه المتواجده في هذه المنطقه
بصوره كبيره هي تحاول تطويق القوات
الاوكرانيه كما تقول القياده العسكريه
هناك من الشمال من الجنوب من الشرق حتى
انها وصلت من الناحيه الشماليه الى منطقه
القطارات وتقدمت الى منطقه صانع كذلك ايضا
تحاول التقدم لم تسقط بعد المبنى
لم تسقط بعد يعني هي تحاول القوات الروسيه
التقدم الى مركز المدينه وسيطره على مقر
الاداره هناك مقر الحكم
مقر الحكم هناك وهذا سيؤدي الى سقوط معظم
اجزاء المدينه لانه له طابع رمز عندما
تسيطر على مقر الاداره التي تحكم هذه
المدينه وكذلك هناك تقدم من الناحيه
الجنوبيه يعني هي القوات الروسيه تطوق
بصوره يعني تحاول ان تكون هناك دائره
كامله حول القوات الاوكرانيه لكن القوات
من الناحيه الغربيه ولكن الصوره من خلفك
احمد هل يمكن ان تشرح لي الصوره من خلفك
يعني دعيني اتحرك يعني هذا هو احد احد
الخنادق الموجوده هنا هناك الكثير من هذه
الخنادق موجوده في كراماتورسك
يعني هذه المدينه بالاضافه الى ماديه ايضا
سلوفس هذه المدينه اذا او هاتان المدينتان
اذا نجحت القوات الروسيه في
صوره كامله على بخدم الى هنا الى وكذلك
الى سفيانسك وبالتالي يسقط يعني او تسقط
منطقه دنياتك بصوره كامله في يده او صوره
شبه كامله
ارتفاعات عميقه في الارض احمد نحن نريد ان
نوضح الصوره اكثر للمشاهدين من خلفك انت
تقف في الموقع لا تمتد لمساحات عميقه هي
يعني
نعم لا يعني هي مسافه طويله بعض الشيء
لكنه تحت الارض حوالي متر من متر ونصف الى
مترين هي المسافه يعني عمقه في داخل الارض
وكما تشاهدين هناك تمويه له
الاشجار
الطين الموجود في هذه المنطقه وكذلك
بالثلج الموجود يعني هذا هذا المكان فيه
ساعات في ساعات البرد الشديد يتغطى يتم
يعني يغطى كاملا بالثلج لكن هذا هو واحد
من كثير من الخنادق
الموجوده ايضا هناك الكثير من الاماكن
والبيوت هنا التي دمرت بصوره كبيره جراء
القصف يعني نحن نسمع القصف بصوره مستمره
ربما مثل الامس يعني البعض كان يتوقع ان
يكون هناك اليوم قصف كبير سمعنا الانذار
لكن الامور لم تتغير كثيرا
في بخمود بصوره كبيره من هذه المنطقه
الساخنه ايضا كراماتورسك انتقل ايضا الى
دونيسكو ولكن نود الاشاره الى هناك جلسه
لمجلس الامن منعقد الان بشان الازمه
الاوكرانيه سنتابع مع حضراتكم فعاليات هذه
الجلسه ولكن نعود ميدانيا الى نقطه مهمه
وحساسه ايضا
الزميل رائد الاغبر رائد العين ستبقى دوما
على دونيسكي لانه هناك تصريحات روسيه
واضحه لن نتنازل عن التقدم الذي احرزناه
في شرق اوكرانيا وخاصه في هذه المناطق
دونيسك كيف تبدو الصوره
رشا بالفعل تستعر المعارك منذ الصباح
الباكر لا تكاد تتوقف القذائف والصواريخ
عن السقوط في المدينه كذلك الدفاعات
الجويه الروسيه تعمل حسب ما تشير السلطات
المحليه هنا بالفعل اصوات الضربات ودويه
الانفجارات
فقط الى كلمه المندوبه الروسي في مجلس
الامن في هذه الجلسه اوكرانيا والرئاسه
ترى ان هناك قيمه في السماح بوزير شؤون
الخارجيه الاوكراني ان يتناول الكلمه قبل
كافه اعضاء المجلس في هذه وفقا للماده
الثالثه
للمذكره 13 ممثله اتحاد الروسي طلب الكلمه
من جديد
لكم الكلمه
السيد الرئيس
اود ان احذركم فحسب ان اللحظه التي
تضع فيها المطرقه
اضفاء طبعا رسميه على قرارك تحدث سابقه
حيث يسمح لي وفد اوكرانيا
بعض الامتيازات تحرم منها اعضاء اخرى
اسمحوا لي اطرح عليكم مثالا من ممارسات
سابقه فالاجتماع حول جمهوريه افريقيا
الخارجيه محاضرا وتحدثها بعد اعضاء المجلس
في 27 من شباط فبراير عقدنا اجتمع حول
مالي وزير شؤون الخارجيه لهذا البلد ايضا
تناول الكلمه بعد اعضاء المجلس في الحادي
عشر من كانون ثاني
نائب رئيس كولومبيا عن وزير وانما النائب
رئيس البلاد السيده منا تحدث بعد اعضاء
المجلس
هذا العام عقد اجتمعا حولها
الخارجيه للجمهوريه دوميني كيا
تناول الكلمه بعد كافه اعضاء المجلس بعد
ان تناول الكلمه جميعا
كما تحدث بعد
كل اعضاء المجلس حول الذي طرا بعد يمكن ان
اضيف الكثير من الامثله
وايضا تحدث بعد كافه اعضاء المجلس لن تكن
هناك حاله واحده او مقترح واحد من الوفود
الغربيه باعطاء الكلمه لممثلين من افريقيا
وامريكا اللاتينيه او اي بلد اخر باستثناء
اوكرانيا
ليعطوا كلمه في اجتماع خاص بهم ويتحدث قبل
اعضاء المجلس هل لك ان ترى
حجم هذا القرار بمنحي هذا الامتياز لوزير
الخارجيه اوكرانيا امام عين العالم اجمع
من جديد اؤكد اننا اي اعتراض على البيان
الذي يقدمه ازير وسنستمع اليه ولكن يجب
الامتثال بالممارسه المعتمده حين ماتته
شاركو وفود تحت المدرسه 37
وتتناول الكلمه من اشهده اليوم ما هو الى
محاوله اخرى لاعطاء بعض الحقوق المجموعه
من الدول
وانتم
ممثلين رئيسيين
تعطونها هذه الامتيازات لانها جزء من
اهتمامات كوميرجي السياسيه وكان بقيه
العالم لا يعنيكم بشيء ونفس المنطق ينطبق
على عدد من الوفود التي دعيت اليوم تحت
الماده 37 12 دوله
من الواضح والجلي ان كل تلك الدول التي
لها نفس الموقف المعتمد الاتحاد الاوروبي
الذي تفرضه عليهم بروكسيل لن
قيمه مضيفه لهذا مضافه الى هذا الحديث
وسيسعون
ضرب في سمعه المجلس فالزملاء من المملكه
المتحده انضموا الى التاريخ
حينما رفضوا مطلبنا بعقد جلسه خاصه طارئه
للمجلس وكذلك امر غير مسبوق يؤسفنا ان
الرئاسه المالطيه مرارا وتكرارا تغض الطرف
عن النظام الداخلي للمجلس وبالتالي تضع
موقفها الوطني ومقدره حد الاوروبي فوق
مسؤوليتها
كرئيس هي رئاسه يجب ان تضمن اعتماد
الاجراءات واعلائها وضمان حياد حياديتها
يجب الاقراء اقرار ان مالطا
لا تطلعوا بهذه المهمه بشكل الوائم يؤكد
على راينا بانه ما من قيمه مضافه لتاوسيع
عضويه المجلس بعضويه بلدان غربيه لانكم
تحول المجلس الى اداه خاصه بكم وشكرا
من جديد احيط علما بكافه نقاط التي تم
الاشاره اليها من قبل ممثل الاتحاد الروسي
هل لي ايضا ان اذكركم على سبيل المثال بان
وزير خارجيه صربي يتحدث امام اعضاء المجلس
وقبلهم ما لا يقل عن مرتين خلال
الاجتماعنا السابقين حول ادمك
اما بالنسبه لقائمه المتحدثين وفقا للماده
السابعه والثلاثين فقد احاطت الرئاسه علما
بان كل الطلبات جاءت من وزراء خارجيه
وقصص الوقت للسفر الى نيويورك لحضور هنا
في الامم المتحده لاحياء هذه الفعاليه
ومما يشير الى ان بلدانهم
كانت ولا تزال متاثره بشكل مباشر من هذه
الحرب
جدول الاعمال
ارحب خالصه ارحاب بسعاده الامين العام
وحضره الوزراء وكافه الممثلين رفيع
المستوى الاخر يؤكد حضوركم اليوم اهميه
المساله قيد النظر اليوم
عملا بالماده 37 من النظام الداخلي المؤقت
للمجلس
ادعو
ممثل كرواتيا والتيكا واستونيا والمانيا
وانغاريا وايطاليا
وهولندا
ومقدونيا الشماليه
واسبانيا واوكرانيا الى المشاركه في هذه
الجلسه
فقرر الامر على هذا النحو
نا بالماده 39 لنظام الداخلي المؤقت
للمجلس ادعو سعاده
الاوروبي
وسياسه الامنيه للمشاركه في هذه الجلسه
تقرر الامر على هذا النحو
يشرع مجلس الامن الان بالنظر في البند
الثاني من جدول الاعمال واعطي الكلمه الان
لسعاده الامين العام السيد انطونيو غوتيرش
السيد الرئيس اصحاب السعاده
المبادئ والمقاصد المرسخه في ميثاق الامم
المتحده ليست بمساله ملائمه فهي ليست حبر
على ورق وانما تقع في لب مهيتنا فهي تعكس
المهمه التي تدفع اممنا المتحده وهي قائمه
اساسا لمعالجه اي مظالم اي مكان قبل عام
مضى جلست في هذا المجلس وناشدت وانا اقتبس
باسم الانسانيه ان لا تسمحوا ان تشن في
اوروبا ما يمكن ان تكون اسوا حرب منذ
بدايه حرب ستكون لها تبعات كارثيه ليس فقط
على اوكرانيا ولا الاتحاد الروسي وانما
ذات اثار كارثيه لا يمكن التنبؤ بها على
الاقتصاد العالمي نهايه الاقتباس
قلت حينها اننا يجب ان نعطي السلامه فرصه
الا انه لم يمنح تلك الفرصه فقد حكمت
الحرب الاحداث انها غزوه روسيا لاوكرانيا
يمثل انتهاكا جسيما لميثاق الامم المتحده
وللقانون الدولي فقد اطلق
العنان لسقوط القتلى واحداث الدمار
والنزوح على نطاق واسع فالهجمات ضد
المدنيين والمنشات المدنيه اسقط الكثير من
الضحايا يؤدي الى معاناه واسعه النطاق
ومكتب المفاوض السامي لحقوق الانسان
وثق الكثير من تلك الانتهاكات مثل العنف
الجنسيه في حاله نزعه والفتيات جسيمه
للقانون الحقوق الانسان ضد سجناء الحرب
والمئات من الحالات للاختفاء القصري
والاحتجاز التعسفي وثقت ايضا السيد الرئيس
تحولت الحياه الى جحيم مستعر للشعب
اوكرانيا هناك حوالي
40% من سكان اوكرانيا في حاجه الى
المساعده الانسانيه وفي حاجه للحمايه
وقضت الازمه على 30% من الوظائف المتاحه
ما قبل الحرب
ويقدر برنامج الاغنياء العالميه حوالي 40%
من الاوكرانيين لا يستطيعون الوصول الى
الغذاء او يحصلون على الغذاء الكافي فقد
ادت الحرب الى ازمه نزوح لم تشهدها اوروبا
عبر العقود
طب انا مع حضراتكم جلسه مجلس الامن التي
احتج فيها المندوب الروسي على عقد هذه
الجلسه والسماح لوزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
بالحضور وبالحديث ايضا ملتهما رئيس المجلس
الرئيس مجلس الامن بالانحياز الى اوكرانيا
تبعه بعد ذلك قرار مجلس الامن بانعقاد
الجلسه بالفعل وكلمه الامين العام للامم
المتحده فاصل ونتابع هذه التغطيه
[موسيقى]
نواصلوا مع حضراتكم هذه التغطيه شكك رئيس
المانيا فرانكشتاين في نجاح مبادره الصين
لتسويه السلميه للصراع في اوكرانيا
وداعشتاين الى الوقوف مع قرار الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده الذي يطالب روسيا
بالانسحاب من اوكرانيا وتسائل الرئيس
الالماني عن مدى فاعليه المقترح الصيني في
تحقيق السلام بين البلدين كما اعتبر رئيس
الالماني انه كان من المفترض على بكين
التحدث ليس فقط مع موسكو بل ايضا مع كييف
اذا كانت الصين فعلا تريد ان تتبنى دورا
بناء في الازمه فعليها في اي حال الا
تتحدث مع موسكو فحسب بل الى كيف ايضا اذا
كانت الصين تريد حلا للازمه فعليها ايضا
ان تنضم الى الاغلبيه الساحقه من الدول في
الدعوه الى السلام تحت مظله الامم المتحده
تسببت العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا بصدع كبير بين القوى العالميه
كما احدثت على مدى عام العديد من
التغييرات في اجزاء من النظام العالمي
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه حاله من التصدع
والانقسامات والكثير من المتغيرات انقسام
بين الكتل الدوليه الرئيسيه بين الشرق
والغرب وسط تباين في المواقف والرؤى حتى
بين الحلفاء اطراف فاعده لعبت دورا بارزا
خلال عام الحرب الاول واخرى ابتعدت متجنبه
الاصطفاف العلني
ونعود مره اخرى مشاهدينا لمتابعه جلسه
الامن حول اوكرانيا وكلمه وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني في اوكرانيا
وقد وقفت
141 دوله عضو بجانب ميثاق الامم المتحده
في حين وقفت سبعه دول الى جانب روسيا ما
من حاجه لاي تفسير اكثر
يعتمد القرار نفس المغزى الذي يعتمده
الرئيس زيلانسكي في صيغه سلام فالهدف هو
وضع خطه من عشر نقاط تستعيد احترام سياده
اوكرانيا وسلامه اقل وسلامتها الاقليميه
وفقا لحدودها المعترف بها دوليا في امتثال
تام ميثاق الامم المتحده الذي التزمنا
جميعا باحترامه واعلائهم بايجاز هدف الخطه
هو اخراج روسيا من اوكرانيا وتحويل العالم
الى مكان اكثر امنا من البديهي ان اي
مقترحات سالم جديده يجب ان تتصق الان مع
المطالبات الوارده في القرار
كافه الدول من ربوع العالم اسري تيسير
تنفيذ القرار وصيغه السلام نحتاج للعمل
معا وبسرعه
وضمانا للامن والسلام النوويين من خلال
دفع روسيا للانسحاب من احتلال محطه
النوويه المحتله بشكل غير مشروع وقف
هجماتها الصاروخيه التي تهدد تلك المحطات
في ربوع اوكرانيا ولتجنب تهديد الجوع يجب
دفع قدما ومبادره الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
وتصدي لجهود روسيا لتقويدها وتطوير
مبادرات اوكرانيا للحبوب ولمنع ازمه طاقا
يجب وقف
الارهاب الصاروخيه الروسي ضد البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه في اوكرانيا اما لحمايه
البيئه
فالقصف الروسي حرق الملايين من هكتارات
الغابات الاوكرانيه مما يهدد جهودنا
الرميه الى التص الاحترار العالمي ولكن في
المقام الاول يجب انقاذ الناس
حياتهم وحقوقهم تقع في صلب
مناضلاتنا للسلام فحجم الازمه الانسانيه
التي تمخضت عن العدوان روسيا ضد اوكرانيا
عظيم وهنا اود ان نسلط الضوء على واحده من
الوقائع المروعه العديده تنفذ روسيا الان
في اوكرانيا ما يعتبر اكبر حاله
لاختطاف الاطفال برعايه الدوله في تاريخنا
الحديث اعضاء المجلس الكرام
ستقاوم اوكرانيا كما كان الحال في الوقت
الماضي وستنتصر
وسيخسر بوتين في فرصه اقرب مما يعتقد
ويجب ان يعرف الروسيون والموظفين ذلك هل
تعتقدون انكم فتخرج
تنفض اياكم من ما قمتم به لا ستمثل امام
المحكمه وستشهدون
بهذا العدوان
هل تعتبرون
ان هذا الدعم
سيضعف اوكرانيا
سيعززنا من قدراتنا هل تعتبرون اننا
سنتعب من الدفاع عن انفسنا مع استمرار
الهجوم علينا سيعضد ذلك من عزيمتنا
وسندحكم في الجميع ان الدعايه الروسيه
اختلقت هذا السردائي بان امداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه سيؤجل الحرب ولكن اوكرانيا تحتاج
لهذه الاسلحه مثل ما يحتاج اليها رجال
الاطفال اخماد النيران فهي تدمر البيوت
وتقتل الابرياء وكلما حصلنا على المياه في
وقت اسرع كلما استطعنا اخماد النيران
وكانت هذه كلمه
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني والتي ركز فيها
بشكل واضح على ان هناك يقين لدى اوكرانيا
انها ستنتصر ملوحا ببعض الملفات المهمه
النووي وايضا ازمه الحبوب وازمه الطاقه
ستبقى العين في هذه الت على هذه الجلسه
وما سيتمخض عنها ولكن هذه التغطيه مستمره
[موسيقى]